[Musique]
1996 un couple d'anglais salies et steve
clarke ont le malheur de perdre leur
premier fils victimes de mort subite du
nourrisson
celle ci est très rare puisqu'elle
touche environ un nouveau né sur 8500
treize mois plus tard leur second fils
décède lui aussi de cette même mort
subite du nourrisson
ça commence à faire beaucoup le pédiatre
reuil mido calcule alors qu'avoir deux
enfants décédés de cette même mort
subite
environ une chance sur 73 millions de se
produire 1 sur 8500 fois un sur 8500 il
en conclut que les parents ont
certainement tué leurs enfants en 1999
sally clark est condamné par la justice
anglaise à la réclusion à perpétuité
pour le meurtre de ses deux enfants
mais cette accusation statistique est
elle censée pour commencer le calcul du
docteur mido suppose que ces décès par
mort subite du nourrisson sont deux
événements indépendants ce qui est faux
puisque le risque de mort subite du
nourrisson est 5 à 10 fois plus élevé
dans une famille ayant déjà connu un tel
drame
ajoutez à cela que le risque est plus
élevé chez les garçons on arrive
finalement à une probabilité d'une
chance sur cent soixante neuf mille que
sally clark et perdu ses deux enfants de
sept mois
c'est tout de même 500 fois plus
probable que ce qu'affirmait le docteur
mido mais ça reste un événement très
rare une erreur bien plus importante a
été commise dans cette situation le
calcul pertinente n'est pas celui pour
madame clark de connaître
tels drames successifs mais la
probabilité qu'elle soit innocente
sachant que ses deux enfants sont
décédés
c'est un calcul de probabilités
conditionnelles est dans cette situation
les mathématiques sont intransigeantes
le calcul rigoureux du document
ci-contre permet de montrer que la
probabilité que madame clark soit
innocente dans cette situation est en
fait supérieur à deux tiers autrement
dit si l'on s'en tient aux statistiques
elle a plus de chances d'être innocente
que coupable l'argument principal de sa
condamnation était donc irrecevable
elle sera libérée en deuxième appel en
2003 alors loin de moi l'an l'envi de
dégrader l'ambiance de cette belle
soirée avec ce fait divers mais il
illustre bien dans un cas aux
conséquences certes tragique
l'utilisation erronée que l'on peut
faire des probabilités et statistiques
celles ci sont très présentes dans nos
vies dans nos métiers dans nos médias
mais aussi dans dans nos administrations
on aux tribunaux nos hôpitaux
et pourtant nous en avons une
compréhension assez lacunaire je vais
vous donner un deuxième exemple dans
lequel une bonne compréhension des
probabilités conditionnelles est
importante
imaginez une société qui fabrique
l'objet de votre choix
j'ai choisi les pièces de lego parce que
j'aime beaucoup les lego une fois
fabriquée
il y a toujours quelques pièces non
conformes qu'il faut mettre de côté
disons une pièce défectueuse sur 1000
pour cela on utilise une machine qui
teste la qualité des pièces après
fabrication
cette machine n'est pas parfaite elle
fait 1 % d'erreurs c'est à dire que 99%
des pièces en bon état sont reconnues
comme telles par la machine et 99% des
pièces défectueuses effectivement écarté
ce tri semble assez fiable intéressons
nous alors
au contenu de la poubelle on s'attend
intuitivement à ce qu'elles contiennent
essentiellement des pièces défectueuses
au vu de la qualité du tri de cette
machine mais comme vous le voyez on
trouve en majorité des pièces en bon
état qui ont été écartés à tort plus
précisément seuls 9% des pièces dans la
poubelle sont réellement défectueuse
la probabilité conditionnelle qu'une
pièce soit défectueuse sachant qu'elle a
été écarté par la machine n'est que de
9%
cela s'explique par le fait que 99 %
d'un millième des pièces restent très
inférieurs à 1% de l'ensemble des pièces
en bon état alors évidemment les
conséquences d'un mauvais jugement dans
cet exemple sont au pire économique
mais imaginez ce qu'il se passe si cette
machine est un test de dépistage d'une
maladie rare ou un test d'alcoolémie ou
encore un test de grossesse la
positivité du test ne garantit pas de
l'être réellement en tout cas pas avec
la fiabilité qu'on imagine d'où
l'importance des prises de sang qui
permettent après le test d'en vérifier
la fiabilité
cette situation c'est le problème du
faux positifs c'est la conséquence d'un
joli calculs de probabilités
conditionnelles qui résident dans la
formule de bèze un calcul très
accessible puisqu'il est réalisable dans
le cadre du programme de l'iss est ce
problème révèle comment notre intuition
probabiliste nous joue des tours
pas sûr que nous puissions nous fier à
celle ci quand il s'agit d'analyser de
manière pertinente
une situation qui contient un phénomène
aléatoire
alors pour vous en convaincre davantage
imaginez maintenant que vous êtes à une
soirée entre amis
ou un grand repas de famille cinquante
personnes sont présents pour l'occasion
à votre avis dans ce rassemblement de 50
personnes y at il deux personnes qui
fêtent leur anniversaire le même jour à
votre avis est ce que cet événement est
probable à quel point utile par exemple
levé la main dans la salle ceux qui
pensent que cet événement à plus de 20%
de chances de se produire mal de main
levée parmi ceux là gardé la main levée
ceux qui pensent qu'il ya plus de 40% de
chances que cet événement se produise
parmi ceux là qui pensent qu'il n'ya
plus de 60% de chances que deux de ces
individus fêtent leur anniversaire le
même jour plus de 80% de chances garder
la main levée j'imagine que si vous avez
encore la main levée vous êtes soit
probabiliste soit très audacieux ou plus
certainement membres de ma famille car
figurez-vous que là le résultat et 97 %
alors même qu'ils ne sont que 50
cette probabilité est encore de 70 %
s'ils ne sont que 30 et écoutez bien
s'ils 23 personnes sont présentes à
cette soirée
la probabilité est encore de 51% plus
d'une chance sur deux comme le montre ce
graphique qui vous donne la probabilité
d'un tel événement en fonction du nombre
de personnes présentes
il est finalement très fréquent dans un
groupe de quelques dizaines d'individus
que deux d'entre eux et le même jour de
naissance
vous vous rappelez peut-être de deux
camarades de classe dans cette situation
vous connaissez certainement autour de
vous dans votre famille deux personnes
nées le même jour notre intuition nous
pousse à croire que c'est un événement
rare
nous avons une vision trop linéaire du
hasard mais comme le montre ce graphique
le hasard lui n'est pas linéaire
et contrairement à ce que l'on croit le
hasard ne fait pas bien les choses
vous avez peut-être une petite parcelle
de terrain sur laquelle vous aimez
planter les graines de vos légumes
préférés en bon probabiliste que vous
êtes
j'imagine que vous souhaitez peut-être
répartir ces graines de manière
aléatoire sur votre parcelle les plantes
et au hasard à quoi ressemblera le
résultat plutôt à la première
configuration en haut à gauche ou à la
seconde et ben majoritairement à la
première configuration de sorte que le
hasard criera naturellement des zones
désertes et des accumulations de graines
sur des surfaces restreintes la deuxième
configuration correspond à la situation
où l'on a imposé qui lie exactement une
graine dans chacune des cases du
quadrillage c'est une répartition
régulière et on confond trop souvent
hasard et régularité alors jusqu'ici on
a vu des situations dans lesquelles on a
du mal à évaluer la probabilité qu'un
événement se produise ses probabilités
sont parfois donné grâce à une
connaissance statistique des évènements
les statistiques ne prédisent pas
l'avenir comme tente de le faire les
probabilités les statistiques décrivent
le passé elle s'appuie sur des données
et des faits qui ont eu lieu ces
statistiques vous en entendez parler
tous les jours dans les médias
tantôt décrié par ceux qui évoquent que
ce ne sont que des chiffres
tantôt utilisé comme argument d'autorité
par ceux qui les présentent comme une
vérité factuelle pour comprendre la
complexité de ces statistiques
intéressons nous à la situation souvent
comme moi vous rêvez peut-être de faire
partie de l'équipe qui crée et invente
les nouveaux modèles lego chaque année
pour ce faire une seule solution s'offre
à vous passer le concours de recrutement
pour le préparer en france
le choix s'offrent à vous l'institut a
et l'institut b l'année dernière dans
l'institut à 18 des 20 filles ont réussi
le concours contre 24 des 80 garçons ce
qui donne des pourcentages de réussite
de 90 % chez les filles et 30% chez les
garçons dans l'institut b 64 des 80
filles ont réussi le concours contre
quatre garçons sur 20 cette fois on a 80
% de réussite chez les filles et 20 %
chez les garçons ainsi que vous soyez
une fille ou un garçon
l'institut a semble avoir de meilleurs
résultats
intéressons nous maintenant à la
réussite globale de ces deux instituts
dans l'institut a on a 42 % de réussite
dans l'institut b 68%
sous cet angle je vous conseille
l'institut b
cette situation c'est le paradoxe de
simpson il montre comment une donnée
statistique
peut-être défavorable à chaque
sous-groupe d'une population 1 par
rapport à une population deux et
pourtant globalement favorable à cette
première population
ce paradoxe ouvre une fenêtre importante
sur la manière dont on peut manipuler
les données statistiques
selon l'échelle choisi pour s'y
intéresser selon la manière de les
décrire on peut en tirer des conclusions
très différentes voire opposées ces
outils mathématiques que sont les
probabilités et statistiques sont
véritablement passionnant et décisif
pour comprendre le monde qui nous
entoure
les mathématiques sont juste et
rigoureuse
c'est l'utilisation que certains en font
qui peut poser problème
il faut garder à l'esprit que de
nombreuses situations probabiliste sont
très contre intuitive rappelez vous de
l'importance des probabilités
conditionnelles
quand vous serez confrontés
un événement rare souvenez-vous de
l'innocence de salies clark et du
problème des faux positifs
si demain vous découvrez que deux de vos
voisins fêtent leur anniversaire le même
jour ne soyez pas surpris
souvenez-vous du problème des
anniversaires et lorsque vous regarderez
tourner la roulette du casino
rappelez vous que le hasard ne fait pas
bien les choses et que les séries de
rouge longue seront fréquentes dans la
soirée aux prochaines élections si le
pourcentage d'abstention dans votre
ville est supérieur à celui dans la
mienne alors que dans la mienne
il est supérieur dans chaque catégorie
socioprofessionnelle de la population ne
criez pas trop vite au complot songez
aux paradoxes de simpson
enfin n'ayez pas peur ni des
mathématiques ni des phénomènes
aléatoires et de ses mathématiques qui
se cache derrière ces phénomènes
aléatoires et qui permettent de les
appréhender accepté de plonger au coeur
de cet univers fascinant en vous méfiant
de votre intuition
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]